hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner koch
will ich heute ein leckeres grill rezept
für euch und zwar mache ich eine leckere
marinade für ein rinderfilet und ich
zeige euch da gleich auch die zutaten
ihr könnt diese marinade natürlich auch
für andere fleischsorten benutzen ich
finds halt total lecker dass knoblauch
mit drin irgendwann mit drin
chili mit drin also eigentlich genau
richtig für mich und ich mache das jetzt
eben mit wind und wetter dann gleich
rinder spieße also print späße machen
könnten aber auch zum beispiel einfach
als steak lassen als deckel oder eben
ganz andere sachen aber ich zeige euch
heute mal so die spielvariante und zeige
ich auch direkte zutaten
ich brauche etwa acht esslöffel olivenöl
dann habe ich hier mein trikot sind 500
gramm ist das rinderfilet aus dem
zwischen rippen stück zu schaffen können
dann frauen chili schoten die sind
ziemlich scharf
ein stück ingwer davon nämlich gerade
sonja so daumen dickes stück je nachdem
wie ticker das stück genauso dick dann
etwas salz pfeffer und curry zum
aufspießen nämlich später zwiebeln rote
die brauchen auch erst später ich brauch
noch vier knoblauchzehen ich habe jetzt
zwei große und zwei kleine das gleiche
aus und habe ich noch bissiger und etwas
rosmarin frischen von der terrasse
gezupft und ich mache jetzt erstmal die
marinade und dann schneide ich das
fleisch zu recht leg ich das weg
also wie gesagt einfach ein stück ingwer
ich schreib mir das einfach so ja so
etwa zwei zentimeter dick ab und dann
müsste dann irgendwann nicht stehlen
sondern einfach hier mehrfach so ein
bisschen abreiben an den haken stellen
und dann geht er die schale eben ganz
leicht runter und vor allem habt ihr
halt nicht so viel verlust an ingo stück
dann schneidet in scheiben und schneidet
auch gleich hier im alligator klein aber
noch die chili schote da können wir
jetzt entweder die kerne rausnehmen oder
elaste drin wenn ich sie drin last ist
schärfer wenig heraus nimmt ist weniger
scharf ich schlafe jetzt drin gerade
dazu entschieden
und dann noch die knoblauchzehe bisschen
flach drücken
die kann man dann ganz einfach stehen
und den knoblauch schneide ich jetzt
auch entscheiden und schneit es dann
auch gleich klein also einfach in kleine
würfel dann und wenn ihr das jetzt so
offen für euch liegen habt das riecht so
leicht asiatisch finde ich gerade es
durch den ingwer den asiatischen
gerichten oft immer mit dabei und ich
finde es richtig richtig lecker also das
nämlich so aromen die zusammengehören
und richtig gut so das ist alles dabei
machen wir's mal nacheinander weil der
immer hat er so ziemlich grobe fasern
beim schiri hatte sitzt den vorteil dass
ich den hut anfassen muss als ich hab
gleich die schärfe nicht mehr an den
händen oder gar nicht an den händen
sondern und beim knoblauch ist egal
meine hände stinke immer noch immer
läuft ich sage immer benutzt
und dann kommt es direkt in der große
schale rein
am besten ist wirklich nicht anfassen
eben wegen den chilis und das was hier
unten mit drin ist so in dieser ablage
es kann auch mit rein gebe dann kommt
jetzt hier das olivenöl mit rein es so
etwa sechs bis acht esslöffel und dann
wird sich das mit salz pfeffer und kari
kari gebe ich grad so einen halben
teelöffel mit dazu das reicht dann schon
und vom salz auch einen halben teelöffel
wird es vermischt sieht auch richtig
hübsch ausfindig
und dann scheiden die kräuter klein da
könnte übrigens auch getrocknete nehmen
aber ich finde es frisch schmecken da
bisserl besser
und dann einfach klein hacken und wenn
ihr diese marinade über nacht ziehen
lassen könnt also wenn ihr am tag vor
ort und zeit habt und was zuzubereiten
müsst ihr die kräuter nicht mal klein
schneiden sondern könnt einfach die
zweige mit darzulegen und sie am
nächsten tag entfernen weil bei frischen
kräuter muss man aufpassen dass die
hatten hat gleich verbrennen
aber das klappt eigentlich ganz gut
kommt jetzt das riecht schon richtig
lecker und frisch und jetzt kann ich mir
schon das fleisch nehmen ich schneide
das jetzt in würfel weil ich ja wie
gesagt hast also nicht schuldig weil ich
schließe machen möchte und ja ihr könnt
aber auch als d klassen oder ganz anders
irgendwie schneiden ist egal
schneider also etwa zwei zweieinhalb
zentimeter stücke
und dann gebe ich diese würfel mit in
die marinade rein
ich habe es noch nicht alles geschnitten
weil ich glaubte hoch apple später auch
wieder so ein steak am stück mal gucken
ich mag es heute eher als spieß dann
vermisse ich das und ich finde sie
einfach echt schöne farben als minister
nicht reingucken
das ist wunderschön jetzt gehe ich da
gleich den deckel drauf und lass es
einfach durchziehen
also mindestens sollte man schon eine
stunde sag ich mal durchgehen lassen
besser über nacht aber bei mir reicht
jetzt auch eine stunde in der zeit kann
ich dann gleich mal die zwiebeln
vorbereiten und den rest vorbereiten und
dann zeige ich euch jemand es gleich
fertig stellt mein fleisch durfte jetzt
zehn durchsehen und ich habe mich
übrigens dazu entschieden dass ich das
ganze andere code alles spitze gleich
macht deswegen habe ich jetzt einfach
alle klein geschnitten und das rate ich
mittlerweile auch da ein bisserl
enttäuscht und rico sicher richtig
teures fleisch und macht spaß draus das
ist so als würde mit seinem elektro und
die blumen gießen
ja aber also erst mal ich hatte eine
nachbarin die hat ihre blumen nur was
das wasser gegeben was sie selber
getrunken hat weil sie exakt
leitungswasser trinken gibt ihre blume
auch nur das beste und beim fleisch ist
genauso weil wenn ich das irgendwie
minderwertiges fleisch und dann werde
die spieße ziemlich trocken und beim
antrieb haben ja auch viel fett drin und
deswegen bleibe die schönste ausschließt
ich finde schon ein bisschen nachhilfe
stunden in kauf nehmen koloss ist egal
wo hat es schmeckt jetzt richtig gut und
dann sind wir alle wieder beruhigt ich
habe die zwiebeln bereits geschält und
schneidet sie jetzt einfach innviertel
da war ein schwäbisches herz alles gut
murat ob groß oder klein das schmeckt
gut
hauptsache sich richtig mariniert außer
dem krieg schon mehr marinade aufs
fleisch muss sie mal dazu sage
jetzt habe ich jedes fleisch
normalerweise würde ich jetzt
einweghandschuh nehmen weil ich habe da
chilli schoten mit drin
ich habe jetzt leider keine also bringt
auch der trick nicht um alligator denn
ich muss die chili schoten jetzt
trotzdem anfassen aber sich nicht
schlimm ist die auge also genau gleich
die hände noch brennen
jetzt nehme ich mir immer so ein stück
fleisch spießt es auf ich glaube ich
musste noch nie wegen roten zwiebeln
weinen dann nehme ich mir zwiebeln grad
so ja ich das mal so zwei übereinander
schließt die mit auf dann mit einem
stück fleisch
du merkst einfach richtig schön zart
auch das fleisch ist also recht gut dann
wieder zwiebel und das ganze eben so
weiter bis man oben angekommen sind
nicht zu dicht einfach dass die hitze da
auch schön durchgang
wir haben also einen tischgrill du
entscheidest tun wie mir das grill
das ist ja immer so weil beim grillen
ist das so der mann gilt ja aber im
prinzip ist so dass die frau das fleisch
vorbereitet die salate vorbereitet die
gäste einlädt den tief steckt das haus
aufgeräumt und putzt dem man das fleisch
auf draußen bringt ihnen das besteck
gibt es weg zurück gibt und er
eigentlich im prinzip das wichtigste
macht und zwar das fleisch auf dem grill
liegt und wieder unternimmt frau legt
man den tisch serviert das ganze zeug
bewertet die gäste räumte nach wieder
auf und dann heißt halt der mann hat
geht wenn dann alles richtig gemacht
alles richtig machst du machst dann
nämlich auch das buch ist grillen
sonntag
so sieht es dann aus richtig hübsch wenn
wir können jetzt aber noch eine cherry
tomate drauf stecke bei cherry tomate
oberliga fleisch
hab ich hier so spießig das jetzt kurz
auf dem rat liegt die kamera weg und
hilft mir ausnahmsweise mit oder nee ich
muss den grill anwerfen
da macht es gleich
so sehen jetzt die fertigen spieler aus
und ich bereite jetzt gleich schon mal
unseren tisch vor dem rathaus den grill
auf und dann wird gleich gegrillt juni
vor gericht richtig gut gehe
krieg richtig vor dem murata den grill
angeworfen
das ist ein grill den kammern halt auch
ihnen benutzten als kann auch jetzt hier
in der küche grille aber ich glaub ich
geh später wieder raus war aus
aber jetzt mal zu zeigen also ich lege
jetzt einfach die spieße drauf das ist
übrigens einer den habe mir auf miles
gekauft und den benutzer mir ganz gern
vor allem wenn wir allein sind oder
nicht so viele leute sind so ist mit
holzkohle übrigens sondern sich wirklich
verschoss mann mann griff mit holzkohle
aber man kann es in der wohnung machen
also ja zu mir sein kind von dir sein
können das bezweifle ich jetzt aber es
ist einfach nur drauf ich finde halt das
gute ist als das fett wasser zu 100
hofft auf die kohle und dann hat man
diese krebserregende stoffe später im
fleisch weil es verbrennt ja dann zu das
hat man hier halten etwa das so ab dass
ich halt geschützt mal das mit platte
drauf ich sag mal so einfach kurz durchs
kühle und ich fände es ein paar mal
ich hab dir jetzt fertig an gebraten
oder gegrillt besatzer gegrillt hab
ich's moratti sieht echt gut aus
nein ich würde mal sagen weil die noch
ziemlich heißen kannst erst später
probieren dankeschön nummer genau und
ich geb dir jetzt hier rein und du
kannst einfach recht an der grille damit
ich klein auf der tischdecke kann dann
ist nämlich deine männerarbeit das
fertig zu grillen
okay er schon besteht balkon dann hab
ich hier nämlich meine ruhe dich nicht
verbrennen
aber ich finde es schon mal richtig gut
aus vor allem so mit den zwiebeln mit
drin mit den tomaten
also ich mag gegrillte tomaten sowieso
ganz gerne jetzt nicht nur wegen der
optik sondern auch wegen dem geschmack
klubs stimmt wenn wir konnten noch den
grünen spargel an
grüner spargel immer gern noch ein
bisserl dazu mache und dann wird bei uns
sitzt gleich richtig schön weiter
gegrillt und wir lassen uns das dann
schmecken wenn ihr wollt dürfte das
rezept gerne nachmachen ich schreibe
auch cds - blog.de auf meinem blog und
iris schmidt gerne ein paar euro
grillrezepte auch mal schicken was ich
mal nachmachen soll wenn ihr da so eine
ultimative rezept habt so eine
ultimative macher marinade oder
irgendwas anderes schickt mir das ganz
gerne ich mache das auch gerne mal nach
und ja ich freue mich schon aufs nächste
mal wieder biss dann tschüss